for the break I asked you to make an
exorcism tutorial video so let's see
what you guys came up with mamrie let's
start with you so after you clean the
vomit off you and pull the crucifix out
of your orifice be sure to exercise your
fingers by subscribing for more vids
that'll make your head spin love you
like an exorcist true
the SkyDrive call to action on that was
falling
thank you yeah all right Hanna you're
next
hey guys it's me Hanna today we're going
to learn how to expel demons that have
overtaken your mortal soul so let's get
started first with some incantations
cool not doodahs danice's dorkus
newsmedia huh oh wow anyway be sure to
click like and subscribe
grace you're next
hey guys it's me again
so step one of today's tutorial is to
make sure that your friend is like
actually possessed and not having like a
seizure or something else gross so once
you've about science you can start
shoving pencils up their ass until the
demons are gone thank you subscribe to
my channel not to Hannah's thank you
I think I have to give everyone 5000
points those are fantastic sick sick
sick